hey rich hey adam uh this is jeremy from
from st michael minnesota and i
first of all just want to say thank you
to rich for the podcast it's been
really life-changing for me um i've been
listening
for about almost two years now i think
and uh the the knowledge and insight
it's given me has been super helpful in
everyday life so
i appreciate it um uh the question i
have
is um for both of you i guess you're
both writers
and i was curious maybe more from the
sense of a personal story
when you feel like you know that your
story
is worth writing and putting out to the
world
and that it might be received and
and kind of um
i don't i don't know exactly how to how
to ask the question but
you know i have a story i have a you
know i've
been through recovery i've been sober
for 15 years i've
you know done some things after recovery
that i feel uh you know would be of
worth for people to hear
and and maybe uh give them hope to
to do things in their own lives and i'm
just
i'm just curious how you come to the the
reality that this might be something
good to put down on paper and that your
story
might be received well in the world so
hope that makes sense
keep doing what you're doing and thank
you bye
all right jeremy listen
of course you should write
your story it sounds like you have an
amazing story i think
everybody should write their own story
and if you have even the slightest
inkling that you want to share something
and that
what you have to share could be helpful
to another human being
of course you should do that i can't
encourage you enough
to write what is inside of you that
clearly i can feel from
from your words is yearning to be
expressed
i sense some hesitancy and perhaps a
lack of
of um uh
confidence around doing this maybe a
little bit of fear
uh and and my sense is that that fear is
linked to
how what you would write will be
received and what you have to do is
let go of that like just who cares how
it's going to be received detach those
two yeah
these are two different things there's
the self-expression there's the telling
and then there's the reaction to it if
you get caught up into the reaction
you're dead out of the gate back to that
can't think about that at all
you have to just basically
get into a place of pure expression
and allow it to you know emanate from
there
i think and you know i can only share my
own experience there's i'll tell two
quick stories
one is how the book finding ultra came
came to be in the first place because it
wasn't like i set out to write a book
i thought maybe in the back of my mind
one day i'll write a book but it wasn't
like i had
set this goal that i was going to write
and write a memoir
right what happened was
um somebody who i didn't know
read about me in um a magazine article
reached out to me by email and asked if
i would be willing to talk to him
because he had just gotten out of
treatment and was having a hard time
and it was somebody that i didn't know
but was somebody that
was friends with other friends of mine
so i struck up a friendship with this
guy and we would talk from time to time
on the phone and i was trying to kind of
help him acclimate to to being newly
sober
and at one point he said
hey you've got this amazing story
have you ever thought about writing a
book and i was like well not really i
mean kind of maybe but like it wasn't
a top of the mind thing and he was like
i know this
book agent you know this book agent
worked with
dean karnaz's and it helped him with his
books and you know you should
would you like me to introduce you like
it was like that right
and that led from one that led to me
being introduced to this book agent and
this book agent being like well if you
want to write a proposal i'm happy to
read it you know this is a tough
thing you could thread the needle here i
wrote i worked really hard on a proposal
and she was still
very you know like grounded in her
you know tried to you know basically
prevent me from having high
expectations and we ended up selling the
book and that's how the book got made
and when i reflect on that story
what i take from it is that the good
thing
whether you can qualify it is good or
not like the fact that i wrote a book
all started from basically being of
service to somebody else like taking
somebody's phone call
and talking to them about recovery that
was it i didn't have an agenda
and that process led to something that i
could have never anticipated
that has changed my life in unbelievable
ways
and in the writing of that book
i had plenty of moments of personal
terror thinking like do i want to be
this open do i want to be this
vulnerable is this a good idea
and i would become paralyzed because i
was thinking about the audience
reception and the only way
that i could get through it was to
completely
block that out and just pretend that i
was writing in a private journal
and that no one would ever read it and
every moment every
you know once in a while i'd have this
flash of like the book being on a shelf
in a bookstore and i would panic
because i would get caught up in that
reception and that ultimately is the
enemy of creativity so
just pretend you're writing in your
personal journey and maybe you don't
share it with anybody and maybe you do
and maybe it impacts one person or maybe
it impacts a million people you don't
know
but the point of the exercise is to
engage with your creative voice and to
try to
you know basically um
be authentic to who you are
i love that so well said and it echoes
something that our friend elizabeth
gilbert
has talked about um which is kind of
in her book big magic she gets into that
a lot is is
um the point is the creative output it's
not the
you have to divorce yourself from
expectation you can't expect something
out of it
um especially when you're first starting
um
because you don't know about that it's
about you don't know where this one act
will take you
uh you know i've never written a memoir
like you but i wrote uh
my the way i got an agent was i wrote an
uh a fictional
novel kind of loosely based on my life
and
i did put a lot of stuff in in there
that was very personal
and um ended up getting me an agent
which helped my you know
got me into into the publishing houses
right
so uh that's how it started for me too
by doing that didn't sell the book
didn't didn't make a dollar off of
middle of somewhere
it's still in it's still somewhere it's
still in my computer though
but you know what i mean but i never you
know obviously i had ambitions for it
but yeah um
but it led me somewhere else and and so
that's the point is
is if you want if you're feeling the
passion you're feeling the urge to
create you gotta
you gotta give it some energy right yeah
right so clearly i could feel
there's something inside of it yearning
to be expressed and that's really
the only important thing
[Music]
you